Plainclothes police out of a car behind her,...
...and Mrs. Thatcher out onto the doorstep.
On the 4th of May, Margaret Thatcher was elected prime minister...
...with the Commons majority of 43 seats.
On arriving at Downing Street,...
...she made one of the most memorable, if not universally well-received speeches...
...of her prime ministerial career.
It's the greatest honor that can come to any citizen in a democracy.
I know full well the responsibilities that await me...
...as I enter the door of Number 10.
And I'll strive unceasingly to try to fulfill the trust and confidence...
...that the British people have placed in me and the things in which I believe.
And I would just like to remember some words of St. Francis of Assisi, which I think are...
...really just particularly apt at the moment.
"Where there is discord, may we bring harmony."
"Where there is error, may we bring truth."
"Where there is doubt, may we bring faith."
"And where there is despair, may we bring hope."